اذا مئه معلن واكثر بينهم افضل 14 معلن
واكبرهم توقف او امتنعوا انصح التعبير عن
الاعلامي فتوه خلال الاسابيع الفائته
والتي وصفت بالفتره الفوضويه التي سيطر
فيها الماسك على المنصه الزرقاء وابهرت
بيانات باثماتيكس وهي شركه تحليل بيانات
التسويق الرقمي اظهرت ان شركه الادويه
مارك وشركه كالوجز لصناعه الحبوب وشركه
فيرسون وشركه بوستن بير قد اوقفت ايضا
اعلاناتها على تويتر في الاسابيع الاخيره
ثم اتت الضربه الكبيره من مجموعه امني كام
للدعايه والتسويق التي اصدرت في الثانيه
عشر من نوفمبر الجاري توصيه لعملائها بوقف
انفاقهم مؤقتا على الاعلانات في تويتر على
المدى القصير ضربه فعليا ومن قام اعتبرت
موجعه لانها تخدم وتعلن عن اكثر من خمسه
الاف عميل في 70 دوله من بينهم مقداللس
وابل وجون سينا جونسون وتؤكد هذه الخطوه
كوكا متزايده بين الوكالات والعلامات
التجاريه حول مستقبل موقع تويتر منذ
استحواذ الين ماسك عليه مقابل 44 مليار
دولار
وتظهر هذه التوترات ان قدره التويتر على
الحفاظ على المستوى السابق لاجراءات سلامه
العلامات التجاريه وفعاليتها قد تكون
معوقه على المدى القريب والادفاع عن نفسه
وسياسته ماسك باللوم على مجموعات الحقوق
المدنيه في انخفاض الارادات بشكل كبير مع
ضغطها على معلنات وتر لمقاطعه الخدمه الى
ان يوضح ماسك كيف سيتحكم في المعلومات
المضلله وخطاب الكراهيه على تويتر وهو ما
لم يتوضح بشكل نهائي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]